politics is [ __ ] up Beyond imagination
no one knows that more than you as
someone that's tried to be an honest
Arbiter of politics for for the last 40
years the bottom the bottom line is the
fact that you and I are have these
differences and don't it's like it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
predictably within the parameter yes of
two human beings the odd the odds the
two human beings would see everything
exactly the same way how pathetic and
annoying and ridiculous yeah and
ridiculous so the fact that you know we
both fall within the 30-yard line it's
like it's how could you expect more than
that or even care that it's not more
than that or not love the person
I
I hear you brother that's all like
that's all I can say about that I hear
you brother what I would like to do more
than anything else honestly I'd like to
shoot hoopsy at some point I I can't
tell you how I don't care about I don't
care that I can continue that I don't
care about the difference I'm sorry I
know you don't either I've said this
before on this podcast I'm going to say
it again since this whole thing started
can I take off my shoes now because then
I'd feel really at home killing it with
guys
I am so many guy friends yeah that I
didn't have before and I'm glad you're
one of them because uh this was super
[ __ ] fun but it's over now that's it
now I got it oh sorry Bill I have to get
on a plane and ring the bell
yes you do